a very warm welcome everyone uh we'll be
starting in more 15 minutes from now
other scheduled time
and thank you for joining
meanwhile we begin with uh today's
webinar it would be great to hear from
all of you about your
background it could be institutional
background on your research background
and also what are your research
interests you can put them in the chat
box thank you
now
yes
oh
a very warm good evening good morning or
good afternoon to everyone present here
um we'll be starting in
more 10 minutes from now
at the schedule time thank you for
joining
good evening dr ajit
good evening dr raghav
good evening good evening everybody
i think we're going to begin with
today's webinars so let me just start
the recording
i would like to welcome you all for
today's webinar on introduction to chem
informatics and drug discovery
it has been well established that
discovering and developing drugs is an
extensive and expensive process
however since 2020 there has been a
phenomenal demand to increase the use of
bioinformatics chem informatics and the
use of machine learning and artificial
intelligence for vaccine and drug
development with the rapidly growing
amount of complex health care and
biological data
and the increasing complexities of
analysis everyday cutting-edge
innovations are bringing new things to
learn hence it is quite challenging for
beginners to start their research
journey in this fascinating field and to
overcome these challenges and bring high
quality research training in the field
of chem informatics and drug discovery
we developed and designed an innovative
and industry driven project based
training opportunity
for everyone
this program will be led by the mentors
of omixlogic industry expert panel which
includes faba prime biotech and science
gurus to help students researchers and
scientists utilize structural biology
and apply chem informatics for drug
discovery
this research training is designed to
enable students to learn basic concepts
of structural biology and to start
applying by working and utilizing
specialized algorithms and tools that
have been utilized by industry and
research labs to innovate discover and
answer some of the important biological
questions
so before we begin with today's webinar
i would like to introduce us we are a
us-based bioinformatics company who is
working with multiple academic and
commercial collaborators to develop
easy-to-use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
the training has been completed by over
24 000 participants from 187 countries
in over 350 workshops and due to this
fast growth our team is working with
local and regional coordinators that are
helping refine the local program
logistics and leverage our online
training resources adapting them to the
needs of students and researchers around
the world
over the past several years we have had
the privilege of working with a number
of organizations developing a training
program from research oriented students
faculty and democratizing bioinformatics
making this discipline accessible to
thousands of students and faculty around
the world
the research-based training programs are
a result of close collaboration between
pine biotech and numerous academic
institutions that have participated in
content evaluation curriculum review and
project design
the training follows a project based
learning approach which uses research
grade tools to analyze data from top
peer-reviewed journals it has been
completed by students researchers and
faculty in six different specialization
tracks which includes oncology
infectious diseases precision medicine
neuroscience data science of biomedical
data
and comprehensive training on omix data
analysis
i would like to take the honor to
introduce the founders and team members
of the company dr alfred tober comes
from a medical background with an
expertise in oncology immunology and
biochemistry of information and one of
his major projects is the establishment
of global bioinformatics research center
which has been at the core of what we do
dr yunan brodsky is the director of
trouble bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
our platform is a result of hard work by
some of the people mentioned here on the
right we'll also hear by some of our
mentors today in the
webinar and i am sonalikari i'm the
omixlogic community manager and i'm
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users that are a part of a
bioinformatics community which is
managed by pine biotech
now let's begin with today's webinar so
first of all i would like to call on
stage dr puneet kakur
dr puneet is an experienced technology
oriented life science professional
responsible for ideation of new
capabilities and end-to-end management
of existing scientific projects
he has an experience in serving clients
coming from human drug discovery
veterinary medicines and agrochemical
settings he's a strong advocator for
using advanced technology and
pharmaceutical research and development
we would like to hear from dr bernith
mentor of the program over to you sir
[Music]
thank you very much
i just wanted to check if you can hear
me
loud and clear
uh yes we can hear you okay thank you
very much thank you for all the
participants joining this call
so uh in this chem informatics program
we will be learning
and
understanding a lot of
traditional as well as new insights that
are coming from the field of
computational
sciences as well as chemical sciences
in game informatics we will be talking
about initially we'll begin the journey
with the chemical structures so all the
stories around chemical structure which
is the core asset of
um
which is the core asset of
the pharmaceutical companies and
all the methods including drug discovery
overall process
modeling simulations
applying machine learning approaches on
the chemical structures and
thinking about something what if we can
automate the whole process of drug
discovery so in case
the participants are coming from a
varied
disciplines
not having a
even a simple understanding of the whole
drug discovery process of what the drug
is i believe this course will be very
ideal for them
they will not only understand the drug
discovery process but they will also
understand
[Music]
how to understand the basics data which
are driving force for the drug discovery
uh data science practice
as well as applying tools in technology
understanding what is available free of
cost what is available on paid
subscription base
all these
tools technology database their formats
understanding the data
when the overall process will be
understood in this program
i will be taking couple of sessions for
the chem informatics center discovery
and i believe i should be the
uh
the right mentor for those courses
because i come with a 15 years almost
experiencing drug discovery and
development
process
helping clients on multiple
areas in chem informatics
drug discovery and development is just
one part where chem informatics can be
leveraged however there's a variety of
other disciplines where there is an
increased demand of
those who
who are skilled in chem
for example if you come from the id
background and you
understand the system of cloud computing
cloud architecture
system architecture and you are trying
to help the clients in in digital
transformation of the
uh in the chemical landscape at their
end
certainly this course will be very very
similar for you
those this extremely large field in
in the healthcare and life sciences
practice where digital transformation
are changing the way
scientists work into their day-to-day
life
doing hands-on on molecular modeling
simulations
running these screening campaigns for
identification of hit molecules are just
a couple of fancy
i would say very very fancy topics that
are
always
discussed in chem informatics
but very fundamental is from where these
chemicals usually comes from what is the
origin of those chemical compounds we
will also understand how
the data what are the databases
associated with these chemical compounds
what kind of informations are generally
stored
when to rely on those information
how you can download those information
how can you consume that those those
information if the information is too
large
what is the best practice to
visualize those information
so all these informations are packaged
together in a
very
nicely
uh
fashion and those camp this chem
informatics
enter discovery
force is is basically designed for that
purpose
i hope you will find this course very
interesting and you will leverage the
information for your
in your current in your current place if
you are a professional you will be
leveraging for your
uh upscaling yourself into the
better
client deliverables if you are a student
then you can upskill yourself for the
job employability if you are an
entrepreneur you can think about what
are the solutions can be made and can
build this startup and
if you are
a phd student or looking for a research
research areas of research topic you
will understand how to select what to
select which topic will have a more
divine in the coming
five years ten years time by the time
when you will be graduated from the
doctoral program i hope in all the ways
this program will be very beneficial to
all of you
i will be mentor for some of these
sessions and looking forward to
meet all of you in the upcoming sessions
starting tomorrow
thank you
thank you so much and dr
dr puni
and now i would like to call on stage dr
mohit mazunga to please introduce
himself
over to you sir
thank you sonalika hello everyone it's a
pleasure to meet you all and i'm very
happy to see dr
uh dr puneet here with us and sonalika
introducing all of us and dr ajit kamath
it's a pleasure meeting you all and i
wanted to discuss a little let let you
all know a little bit about my
background so as a mentor i've been uh
working with pine biotech for the last
three years helping students understand
some of them important aspects of
structural biology and also applying
some of these chemi informatics methods
for their drug discovery projects along
with that uh we've been working together
with
faba academy
science gurus and other
other academic
partners where we are developing uh
resources and tools which will be really
helpful for you to learn about chem
informatics and drug discovery that you
learn throughout this program so this
entire program has
been uh designed keeping in mind about
different backgrounds of students coming
from different
educational systems as well as uh under
keeping a basic understanding of what is
going on in the industry so as you have
heard from dr puneet that you would be
learning about some industry
opportunities uh some academic
opportunities so
it is also important to understand that
uh what are the different methods that
industry is using for different problems
so in this program we will be discussing
that and as as my experience i have over
30 publications in structural biology
area where i've worked with different uh
academic researchers and scientists from
all around the globe focusing on finding
solutions
using computational modeling and
molecular dynamics simulations and
finding
specific key mutations to do
to plan
experiments as well as to do some
translational work uh to find some
uh different types of variants and to
look into their change in the active
site so in this program we have also
used all of those
methods that is usually applied for
chem informatics that is usually in
application in research so this will be
a program which will be really
beneficial for those who are coming to
learn about chemi informatics as a
application to drug discovery but also
structured biology and the different
aspects of structural biology and what
this chemical data and
protein information and biological
information we can extract and
the mechanisms that we can look into
using all these different aspects of
structural biology and chemi information
so i'm very very excited for this
program and i'm really looking forward
to
working with all of you
with different ideas working with all of
you with different
tools that we will be using throughout
this program along with this great
mentors that we have along with us which
is uh dr uder saxena co-founder
and region's bioscience and is a
renowned professor and he's been taking
a lot of a lot of
sessions and we have the other mentors
as well so looking forward to meeting
you all and
then working through the sessions and
the practical aspects thank you so much
thank you so much dr mohit
now i would like to
invite dr ajit kam
who will be talking about the
advancements in drug discovery dr ajit
has 25 plus years of pre-clinical drug
discovery experience primarily advisor
he obtained his phd in biochemistry from
the indian institute of science and
carried out post-doctoral studies at the
university of texas austin and stanford
university dr arjeen joined pfizer's r d
center in groton city and cambridge and
worked there for 13 plus years as an
associate director and after 20 years in
the us he returned to india and served
as senior vp algebra and biosas for four
years
dr ajit iii joined pfizer as the head of
external r d innovation worldwide r d
pfizer india and successfully initiated
collaborations with indian pharma
companies and academia his team country
contributed to two drugs one in the
market and one is in clinical trial dr
ajit also worked at mithra biotech as
executive director to lead their
external research efforts
currently dr ajit is an advisor to two
startup companies pandora technologies
which focused on corneal blindness lung
and liver diseases and and
mr stop solutions working on cancer
metastasis
he is the member of some of the dbt
birac committees as well which includes
big bionist and national biopharma
mission we are pleased to have you among
us dr ajit over to you
spash i think you need to make doctor
ajit cohost
he's really co-host
thank you
can you can you hear me now
yes we can hear you okay okay yeah so
i'll uh
uh you know i'll start sharing my screen
okay you can you see my screen
yes so we can see your screen okay okay
thank you um first of all thank you very
much
for the kind introduction and mohit uh
you know for for all the interactions
that faba academy has with you and with
find biotech uh thank you
and i would like to thank uh
pine bio for this opportunity to
interact with the youngsters uh
potentially they will all be joining
your courses in
gaming informatics and take advantage of
you know mentors like mohit and uh
and others who have agreed put a nice
program like this together
in my presentation i mean suggested that
i keep it basic so that you know many of
the beginners will be able to understand
so i will be talking about the recent
advances in drug discovery and covering
quite a number of aspects it's nice that
uh you know all of you have an
opportunity to learn
during this course uh the power of chemi
informatics
it was not there
as sonata mentioned the beginning you
know the technology has changed
tremendously and it's all for good okay
things have worked out very well things
the technology is moving
excuse me
moving so fast and
that those things have helped drug
discovery to go you know much faster
than what it was i would say you know 10
20 years ago when many of us started our
drug discovery uh journey in companies
such as such as pfizer
so as sonalika mentioned you know i um
until recently i was a
uh uh senior director and head of
excellent r d for pfizer
uh i am also currently advisor for
pandarum technologies and senior advisor
for mr stop solutions which is working
on cancer
metastasis
the opinions and the content that i have
in my slides they're all my own
are adopted from the literature adopted
from publications and they reflect my
um
you know my own
ideas and opinions and do not
reflect that of my farmer or current
employers okay
so what we'll do today is uh discuss
about uh you know various aspects of
drug discovery again i'm trying to keep
it basic certainly we can
get back to some of these
deep dive into some of these areas
depending on the interest at a later
time and we can certainly coordinate
that with the
sonalika so the topics i'm going to
cover uh would be
introduction to a drug discovery process
let's talk about high throughput
screening we'll talk about structural
biology and structure based drug design
uh some of the selectivity screens that
are employed in the pharma industry
we'll learn a little bit about biology
not much
and then talk about uh discovery of this
authentic one of the kinase inhibitors
for lung cancer and then we'll summarize
okay but the message in all of these
would be how fast the technology has
changed and how fast you know people
have been able to imp implement these
technologies so that will be able to
come up with medicines much faster for
various diseases
and that is i think
that is the theme of the entire chemo
chemist informatics course where you
know so much of knowledge um
data that's being uh
you know cranked out is analyzed very
very thoroughly made sense of it and
then utilized
for coming up with medicines
drug discovery as such is a
is a long process okay
it takes uh about 15 years uh 10 to 15
years to come up with the new drug and
the entire process starts as
as shown here okay
you start with an idea okay we can
i can
get into some of these interesting
topics uh anytime in the future so a
team what we call it normally call it as
a project team
i hope you can see the
the
cursor arrow
yeah
okay
okay yeah let me take a pen
yeah you can see the laser pointer
sonalika yes
okay okay yeah so a project team let's
say a project team working on cancer
means together and say you know this is
the target that we would like to id uh
we would like to start with you know use
that particular target and
develop one
develop a very very selective and highly
important drug so that's that's called
the project team
involving lots and lots of scientists
with the different backgrounds some are
chemistry some more biologists some are
pharmacologists
uh there will be you know
people specialize in admin safety
toxicology all of them will be sitting
together and saying okay how do we
address this particular target and
convert that into a nice nice uh
in this particular case maybe small
molecule and take it into
uh into the patients later on so if it
is a small molecule then you know you go
through synthesis you go through a lot
of screening i think kuni talked about
it and i'll come back to this at length
um during my presentation and then you
know do a lot of discovery work okay at
the end of the discovery work you you
start nominating a candidate after
carrying out initial safety studies and
let's say you identify a candidate that
has that is very very safe selective and
is ready to move into into the clinical
stage okay so you you
carry out some more safety studies long
term safety studies and finally you know
you make it in kilogram quantities in a
gmp manufacturing facility and then try
it in healthy patients
sorry not patient subjects okay these
are
volunteers um
perhaps you know 20 to 30
uh
subjects in this particular case who are
uh who are participating in the study in
phase one
you demonstrate the safety of that
particular compound and then you get
into what we call it as phase 2 full
development with 100 to 300 patients and
then you if everything goes well there
then you move into another
phase three which is the most critical
part ranging from somewhere between you
know
300 to 3000 to 10 000 to 30 000
patients okay and these are real
patients and you analyze the data if
everything looks good if it is very very
efficacious in phase three then
you you nominate
the drug and it is uh reviewed by usfda
or in india it's a cdso or dcgi and
finally if all of them approve the drug
comes to the market okay so this is the
normal process of drug discovery that is
followed
over a period of
somewhere between you know
10 to 15 years
but the success rate in drug discovery
is very very low
if you start with 100 drug discovery
programs they're in
your team of people
[Music]
sorry a team of people working on drug
discovery and if you have 100 project
teams working on
100 different programs and you screen
let's say a million compounds uh we need
to talk a little bit about it and then
you know go through pre-clinical
pharmacology safety pharmacology uh and
then eventually you'll be able to get
one or two drugs to the
apologies one or two drugs to the market
over a period of 15 years
okay this is the
you know
this is a challenge with drug discovery
very very long time process and
you know it takes around 2 billion
for for my
colleagues you know coming from india
this will be about 15 000 crores just to
come up with one particular drug taking
15 years that's a very very long drawn
process with the uh with the you know
about two percent three percent of
success rate and
you know many of us who worked in this
industry for 20 plus years have
essentially worked on about 100
different programs and then have one or
two products in the market so you can
imagine the amount of time and effort
that takes to bring one drug to the
market okay but this can't
be uh this can't continue okay things
have to change and this is where you
know all the new technologies that are
coming into the picture have helped to
accelerate the entire drug discovery
process okay but why would the drugs
fail
the drugs fail for a lot of reasons
the drugs are becoming the diseases are
much more complex okay because we have a
better understanding of the diseases the
drug is not supposed to stay too long in
the body if they stay too long in the
body again you know it can cause
toxicity the drug
there will be some adverse reactions
there will be poor absorption of the
drug and
and there are instances of very low
levels in the body everything looked
good in animal studies but when you get
into the human body you know the levels
remain so low that that drug is no no
longer efficacious so there are a lot of
reasons why
the
the drugs fail and
the most important thing that we'll
discuss perhaps you know in my next talk
on personalized medicine is the
contribution from genetic makeup of the
patient population okay i think this
particular factor
most of the
companies did not take into account for
years and years we all thought that all
of us are the same if the drug works in
patient a it should work on patient b if
the drug works on you know people in the
united states it has to work on people
in europe in india and china and and
everywhere else but in reality that is
not true and that's all because of the
understanding we have about
genetic variations among among people
genotypes are different for different uh
people from different
countries different genotypic orange
origins and they all contribute to
uh you know success of the drug or
failure of the drug and we'll discuss
much more of this in the personalized
talk that i'm going to give on friday
so as i mentioned in the last 15 20
years now as we have the human genome
sequence available you know it has
tremendously
changed in fact revolutionized the drug
discovery because we know everything
about a human
human genome we know what are all its
components what are the genes that are
there what are the functions for most of
the genes okay
how many enzymes are there in the
in the human genome what type of enzymes
how many receptors are there the role of
karmas all these are very well
understood now thanks to human genome
sequence available and
as puneet mentioned now it's a time of
opportunity for
for all of us to incorporate some of the
very new cutting-edge technologies into
drug discovery okay we have a better
understanding about diseases
10 20 30 years ago when we talk about
oncology we talk about you know a
very very broad disease as oncology but
in reality it is not okay there are
hundreds of types of cancers and
and each of them have a unique way how
the how that particular cancer started
and how you can control that it's not
that cancer is one and then you have a
a simple drug that can uh i mean a
common drug that will
that can be used for all types of
cancers so we are under we will discuss
more about this in my next talk
but the biology insights have been
fantastic we have very good targets in
the past they were not druggable but now
they are druggable okay so
that also has contributed a lot and then
of course
a lot of very powerful technologies
technologies such as chemi informatics
technologies such as robotics
uh technologies in high throughput
screening all these have
really helped us to look at targets that
that were
you know
uh uh undraggable in the past and now uh
thanks to the technology we are able to
do much better in using
in using these technologies to
to target those and then identify small
molecules
uh small molecule drugs and now is the
era of
omics again it's a i think this workshop
and the previous workshops arranged by
time bio will certainly help all of you
to understand the
the role of each of these specific areas
whether it is genomics transcriptomics
proteomics metabolomics all of these are
very very important in understanding how
you
decipher the disease and what type of
molecules you can develop okay
again 10 20 years ago 30 years ago these
are
all in nascent stage
people are not looking into these uh
these areas of omics but now it is
integral part of any of the drug
discovery programs so the the course
that that your
that pine bio is offering on omix is
whether it is uh you know chem
informatics or the regular uh omics will
cover many of these things and you start
appreciating as to how these
technologies is going to help in drug
discovery
in in drug discovery you know there are
phases
we call it as
the heat identification target to heat
identification
hit to lead and then lead optimization
and then proof of concept studies and
eventually you nominate a candidate at
this stage that candidate can get into
uh
the
clinical study okay so these are all the
various phases i will not get into the
details uh of this but
once you start screening with the
hundred thousand compounds or a million
compounds or
three to four million compounds at the
end of it you will end up with one or
two compounds with a lot of confidence
and these molecules will get into the
clinical study that is the phase one
clinical study okay so how does uh uh
for for scientists like us how does this
uh start at the beginning i showed you
one slide where the project team is
sitting and discussing you know how do
we come up with the molecule and this is
what exactly they do okay you identify
an inhibitor which eventually will
become the candidate
for the
for the clinical trial and that is
against one particular target and let's
consider that as a target protein
a target that has been implicated in one
particular disease and you want to
inhibit that particular
protein so you you produce that
particular protein and then develop
assays you will see this in my future
slides okay once you have that assays
developed you run the high throughput
screen to come up with the some
molecules those molecules you discuss
with medicinal chemistry they'll make
more molecules that are very selective
and very potent you use that knowledge
to screen more
more
enzymes more targets develop structure
based drug design effort and then you
know you go through selectivity screen
so that your molecules are very very
selective okay and then of course you
know biology comes into the picture
um in meteorology in vivo vivobiology
that is pharmacology and make sure that
the compound is applicatious the
compound you know is very stable not
degraded
does not have any toxic properties
that's called that is done using admi
and then pkpd studies and everything
else if it passes through all then you
have a potent preclinical inhibitor
pre-clinical molecule that you can take
it for glp talk studies and eventually
take it into the clinic
and this is this normally takes three to
four years but
thanks to all the technologies that uh
that are currently available it is about
you know two to three years now
depending upon what type of uh target
protein you are working on okay
so uh
the the same information in the previous
slide i've converted this into
into this slide wherein
we are talking about various components
of drug discovery
you know there's high throughput
screening there's medicinal chemistry
the structural biology and structure
based drug design
structure activity relationship or we
call it as sar okay then of course
biology is there with the you know
biochemical assays
um cell based assays uh developing
various uh in vivo models to show the
efficacy of the molecule pharmacology
studies pkpd studies and then of course
you know glp torque study which
really tells you whether the molecule is
safe
or you have to you have to kind of you
know abandon the project
so
in today's presentation i i'll
focus quite a bit on high throughput
screening because the the the chemi
informatics coursework will cover some
of these things as highlighted by
sonalika
mohit and and puneet so we'll talk a
little bit about it and also i'm sure
you will appreciate how things have
changed um
for the better with regard to high
throughput screening we'll talk about
structural biology and its impact on
drug discovery again you will learn a
lot about this in the course and then of
course biology is important you'll you
will hear some aspects of it in my
presentation okay
i wanted to
highlight you know the power
[Music]
of expression profiling in this
particular uh
in this particular presentation okay so
all of you are familiar with the dna
that is uh you know genomics convert
into rna
that is transcriptomics and then
ironing becomes protein and then prot uh
is converted into protein and protein
you know uh has various functions and
eventually you you it has role in
developing all the metabolites that are
used so
in
in the past i think we were just looking
at this alone um and then hoping that
you will come up with the target protein
and then you know inhibit that
particular protein so that the
metabolite is not formed okay and that
is essentially you know the small
molecule drug discovery i as an
inhibitor whereas now
uh thanks to the technologies all these
components are um day-to-day utilized
day-to-day uh in in drug discovery
process whether it's genomics
transcriptomics proteomics and then
metabolonics okay it is no more saying
that you know i have one particular
target you have to go back and see what
does that particular protein do what are
its metabolites what are the
transcriptome
transcriptomics profile you know how
does the genome look are there any
mutations what happens if there is
mutations all these things come into the
picture and that is what is demonstrated
in this particular slide okay so we
let's say we are trying to identify
you know what is causing a disease okay
how do you understand the difference
between a normal tissue or a normal
uh you know subject versus
a
a
patient who has who has a disease okay
in this particular case i'm giving an
example of expression profiling done for
breast cancer okay
um
in this particular case you have the
normal tissue okay
and this is the uh profile uh expression
profile of perhaps 20 000 uh
you know
genes okay looking at looking at all the
profiles there this is normal and look
at the cancer tissue you know
how
over expressed many of those genes are
okay and this is from the same patient
is this a neighboring tissue okay this
is the
non tumorous tissue and this is a
tumorous tissue of the brass showing you
you know how many of these genes that
are listed here are are over expressed
and they are the they are the ones that
are causing the you know um
uncontrolled self proliferation leading
to uh leading to the tumor formation
okay and
and you can see exactly this what
happens a lot of uh you know
a lot of pathways i'm sure you'll hear
more about it during the in the
uh during the course of course of this
work
this this workshop okay various pathways
involved in uh
in nucleotide biosensors they're all
over extras because
the the cells have to make so much of of
nucleotides for for the for the growth
of the tumor okay so this this tells you
that there are opportunities for you in
this particular case inhibiting some of
these pathways okay using um using small
molecules and perhaps you know if they
are working very very effectively then
you'll be able to
stop the uh the growth of the tumor and
hence uh you know
the patient
can get better okay so i just gave you
that as an example to show how
uh unlike what it was 10 20
years ago how people are looking at
targets and now
without
data such as such as this one it will be
very hard to carry out any drug
discovery work most of this again you
will learn in this workshop and and it
will greatly benefit you if you are
taking up a job in the industry or in
your research itself okay let's quickly
move into other aspects of
of
the discovery uh hds
let's say we want to do a hds for an
enzyme target we assume that this
particular
target is critical in
uh
in in
in one particular disease let's say
cancer it might be a kinase there are a
lot of
enzymes i'm putting this list because
all of you may have worked on many of
these are familiar with this so
um so
in a pharma industry same targets are
utilized for coming up with drugs and in
this particular case let's talk about
the kinase okay
so kinases have been implicated in
various diseases particularly in cancer
but they also have have been implicated
in neurology metabolic diseases
inflammation immunology that everywhere
okay but cancer is a place where you
know there have been a
large number of drugs for kindnesses
have been developed and they are
currently you know
being given to the patients as a
tyrosine kinase inhibitors or tkis okay
there are 518 kinases okay
and all of them have a role in
various signaling pathways which many of
you have have studied a lot and also you
will hear some of that in this in this
particular workshop so
a protein is phosphorylated in the
presence of atp you get phosphorylated
protein and this particular
phosphorylated protein you know
eventually phosphorylates others in the
pathway and eventually you will see the
cell proliferation uh uh
leading to leading to tumor that that's
an example that i'm going to highlight
today okay
may in this particular pathway there are
so many uh i'm sure you have read about
all these pathways there map kinase
pathway and that you see so many targets
have been identified okay
all these are kinase inhibitors and if
you inhibit this particular kinase then
you know the
proliferation or differentiation comes
to an end that means the tumor doesn't
grow thus the tumor dies so that you
know the patient becomes normal that is
the hypothesis in which you work on and
these are all the various drugs that are
currently available
around the world developed by various
pharmaceutical companies to address
to address
various types of cancer so we have about
80 different kinase drugs that are
developed um as of december 2021 okay uh
i i suggest you you go through this
review um nature review drug discovery
by phil cohen
who is a fantastic
leader in uh in kindness okay he wrote
this review on
you know on oncology drug development
okay so if you want to come up with a
drug let's get back into basics since
most of you are beginners and
you know students i would like to
emphasize how exactly the drug
disclosure works many of you would have
cloned some genes and that's what
exactly happens in the pharma industry
you isolate a kinase gene that's of
interest and that particular kinase gene
has a role in in
in a given disease okay you isolate it
from cdna clone it into into expression
vector either in e coli either for
expression in nuclei or in bacilla virus
system or mammalian system
express express large quantities of
cells grow a large quality large amount
of cells and then purify the protein
develop the assay you characterize it
and then in this particular case use
them for inhibition studies but also for
crystallization which we'll talk a
little bit later okay this is to
emphasize the purification people use
various tags and i'm just showing you
one example where we purified
we have purified large number of
you know kinases okay and i'm giving an
example of some of the kinases that we
purified akt
fe2 you know irk and check two and
sulu and stlk2 and various kinases all
of them have specific roles in in cancer
okay
so once you purify the protein obviously
you know you would like to run sdsp gels
gel permeation to make sure that the
protein is clean i mean protein is pure
okay you run western blots you run mass
pack to confirm the identity of the
protein internal sequencing you
characterize the substrates do all the
enzyme
characterization such as
ph metal atp peptide chemistry uh use
peptide concentration optimization and
other things so there are multiple
things that that will have to do to
characterize uh the the target the
enzyme that are used for high throughput
screen
uh
then you carry out the assay development
i'll not get into the details uh here
but this is i think all of you have read
about it in in your in your coursework
so i'll skip this one
and you know i'll skip this one also
this is regarding ic50 determination i
just wanted to highlight that you know
many of you have worked in the lab
carried out your research project and
this is not different this is this is
the same
except that in the pharma industry you
you do it in a very very robust way in
large number
of
you know molecules are being screened by
the high throughput screening okay
uh high throughput screening you not do
it for millions compound scale
and things have changed you know people
run
a hundred thousand compound library but
others still go with million compounds
library you can screen
structurally diverse sub collections you
can
go with the fda approved drugs or kinase
inhibitors
you can go with natural products and
there are a lot of ways in which you can
run a library
okay
libraries against targeted kinases you
can run against proteases you can run
against phosphodiesterases so there are
sub categories of molecules that you can
use for hydrogen screening that is with
the assumption that more compounds you
have better chances you have of
identifying a molecule and that need not
be true okay you have to have a high
quality compound that probably gives you
high quality compound with lot of
diversity has a better chance of success
and you have to have a better good
quality assays then again you know you
have high chances of success okay and
then you have library we call it a
singletons and compress library
some of it i think may be covered in the
in the
workshop
chem informatics workshop okay so if you
are running
a high throughput
screening then you have the assay
developed we talked
in previous slides how we develop the
assay
now you have the library you screen
uh against you know these millions of
compounds in the primary screening okay
and then you recheck it again we call it
as retest or confirmation
concentration dependence
that's ic50 determination and finally
you come up with the molecule
it's a lead molecule but at this stage
we call it as a heat and then you have
to improve the property before it
becomes a lead and eventually you know
you'll be able to
[Music]
carry out the efficacy study on these
molecules okay
how do you run high throughput screen
okay and how do you analyze the data and
that's where you know all these
technologies come into the picture
uh there are a lot of
you know
spectroscopic techniques such as uv
plural science imminent
[Music]
and technologies that we can use for
running screen people use mass pack
people use gc hplc
various technologies are available in
addition to you know the the
very well known radioactive assays
people are
going away from radioactive assays
because of potential uh you know effects
of radioactive materials um it's all
people focus more on
non radioactive methodologies
particularly with spectroscopists if you
can
if you can adopt that
and now comes the data okay
talked about it i'm sure you will hear
much more in the workshop how do you
analyze this data okay let's say you
have
one million compounds you have so much
data one million compounds perhaps from
say thousand or two thousand three
thousand chemical series
okay
in fact it it will more than that okay
so you have thousands and thousands of
molecules
okay you want to visualize all of it
this is actually you know
for most of us biologists this is
something you know we always wait for
okay when the chemists are when we run
all the screen the chemists are sitting
together the chemi informatics everybody
is sitting together and saying okay tell
me
okay you ran against one million
compound tell me the best molecules how
do they look
okay show me the best inhibitors that
are there best series which can which we
can work on so this is
answering you know months and months of
work of all running the screen and
everything else and this is essentially
the type of output you would like to
that you get and then you know then the
informatics team and rest of them sit
together and say okay you know from this
the following molecules following series
are good and you can adopt that and then
you know put more record i just wanted
to highlight this particular heat map so
that you know to tell you how things
have
improved
tremendously in the past few years
wherein we are visualizing
million compounds in one particular
slide
the limitations of pythagoras screen
requires very very expensive instruments
the reagents are very very expensive
and of course if you're running million
compounds i mean a lot of time is also
required though you know
things like being miniaturized now and
you'll be able to run one particular
screen perhaps in in one week with one
million to two million compounds but
still you know it's lot of a lot of work
okay
and this is this has been going on for
years and recently
people have moved on
to develop libraries using dna coded
libraries how and how they have
revolutionized the drug discovery okay i
want you to go through some of these
fantastic technologies that are coming
up wherein you are able to screen you
know
40 trillion
molecules all these are dna encoded
libraries and
you know they are developed by companies
such as
new evolution
and these are
being used now for drug discovery okay
and i also wanted to quote the ceo of
the company saying that you know don't
think of 40 trillion is a large number
you can put all of them in elephant
okay
okay so and then you will be able to
screen and the recent studies do show
that there have been successes of such
an approach of dna encoded library and
these are the two three molecules from
gsk that are in the clinic and from
from astrazeneca that are in the clinic
all started using this particular
technology you can do a google search um
for this particular technology if you
are interested and you will get to know
more as to why
you know um dna encoded libraries have
become very very popular let's look at
one more example of doing the
the previous one is a real
library okay and this particular case
is a virtual screening
with the tree three trillion compound
library it's a cutting-edge technology
developed by a company in california
called atomwise okay in collaboration
the company
in in china called ho uh
pharma okay
in this particular case you know they
they
do lot of uh in silico screening again
in this workshop
you'll get to know a lot more from mohit
and others about the power of in silico
screening in this particular case you
know they don't need crystal structure
which is uh you know which is very good
because most of them have this structure
but without that also you'll be able to
use it and you don't need local ligand
training data some of these are
propriety technologies that they develop
but supposed to be
giving them fantastic results and all of
it is done by
screening this trillion compounds in
silico and come up with the molecule
okay and these molecules are
synthesized in the lab okay so from
three three trillion compounds virtual
screening
you come up with perhaps about thousand
compounds which are very good you go
back to the lab
work with the collaborator and then
they'll make you those thousand
compounds you you test those
in the lab in the in the assay okay
again all these technologies are
possible only using tools that i think
you will you will hear more about it
you'll learn more about it in the uh
informatics workshop okay
so we looked at one aspect uh
uh i i i may need about 15 20 minutes uh
i hope that's okay
yeah
uh
i'll cover i'll cover some aspects of
in addition to structural biology which
is one approach the other approach is
looking at structural biology and
structure based drug design okay
[Music]
if you have the structure of a protein
and you know where exactly
the the compound is binding then you
will be able to
uh
you will be able to develop molecules
rationally you can design molecules that
bind very tightly and very effectively
in this particular case this is the
binding site for a kindness and you will
be able to
develop molecules and this is approach
you will hear more about it in the
workshop as to how this also has greatly
helped in developing molecules for for
various diseases
i'm giving an example of kinase a um in
this particular case this kinase a was
expressed in e coli
purified crystallized you saw the
structure and
here is the structure of this particular
enzyme that is it's a kinase it has a
binding site and this is where
this atp binding site and the inhibitors
bind in this particular site and you
will be able to
[Music]
you know look at the active site
residues and then design the molecule
uh
that will bind tightly here okay and
then you can you you can
you can make a lot of analog around it
and then try to come up with the
molecule that will essentially
uh
that will be a very potent selective
molecule okay another example for you uh
another kinase again purified
crystallized uh and structures solved by
x-ray diffraction okay and then you know
you get to see where the inhibitor is
binding okay a few more examples of
protein purification and getting
crystals and solving structure okay
[Music]
all this is possible because of the
recent advances in technology when when
many of us started working on this 10 um
20 30 years ago you know we would do two
clone two genes three genes at a time
but now you have robots that can do high
throughput cloning robots that can do
high throughput cell culture you don't
have to grow one cell at one clone at a
time you can do 96 at a time okay if not
more you can purify
you know 96 proteins at a time using
various technologies and then you can
use crystallization machines that can
crystallize you know in
nano liter
samples and then try to get you the
crystal structure and then you can use
you know synchrotron
this is an example of synchrotron uk
where you can ship your crystals and
they will collect the data for you and
in fact you can sit in your office here
in india or wherever your lab is and you
can collect data uh remotely okay so
that is the power of technology
that is
that is helping us to come up with drugs
much faster okay
so you identify
in this particular case i'm giving an
example of a kinase atp binding site is
binding here and you know this is these
are all the interactions that are there
for this particular inhibitor with
various residues in the active site i'm
sure you will hear much more about it in
my presentation okay
this is a plk one
a project that we worked on many many
years ago at pfizer
it has n terminal lobe and then a c
terminal lobe and an activation log okay
and this is uh the atp binding site okay
[Music]
i would like to get into some details
here this is the atp binding site of
of plk one of the enzymes
that is targeted for cancer but you know
you would like to identify molecules
give at the act at a selective site
selectivity site or activation loop site
or
dfg in dfg out so that you will get more
selectivity this is classical site this
is non-classical site okay
because there are so many other
kinases that have the atp binding pocket
okay
getting getting selective molecules are
quite challenging for kinases but people
have been able to get it okay there are
518 kinases and all of them have the
same kinase
atp binding domain so the residuals will
be similar so how do you get selectivity
so that's a challenge there are 2000 atp
binding proteins they have the atp
binding pocket too similar to kinases
how do you get selectivity there and
then of course you know there are
multiple phospholipid forms
non-phosphorylated forms somatic
mutations alternate pathways so
though we think that we are we know
kinases very well getting
a selective inhibitor for kinase is
always a challenge
once you have uh
once you have an inhibitor towards a
towards a kindness you always develop
something known as connex selectivity
screening okay so that you will be able
to make sure that the kinase that you
are inhibiting is selective only for
that particular kinase and it does not
hit remaining
517 different kinases okay i'm giving an
example of using 50
kinases
okay for developing a selectivity screen
uh this is these are all the examples
this is a kind of tree which
i'm sure you are all familiar you pick
up you identify you some of these
kinases that have that are important for
your disease but also you want to have
some kindnesses you don't want to touch
kinases that have a role in kidney
function you don't want to inhibit
kidneys function you don't want to
inhibit cardiac
function many kinases have a role there
so you want to make sure that your
compound is selective to one particular
kinase which you want to inhibit but
does not inhibit other kinases okay so
imagine
you have thousand compounds or ten
thousand compounds you are running
against in this particular case are
given fifty kinase examples assume you
are running against three hundred
kinases
look at the data that you can generate
okay again informatics come to the
picture to identify you know how would
you go about identifying which is which
inhibitor binds to which of the kinases
and causing the least side effects okay
this is just one of the heat maps that
you can see but imagine
running this heat map with 1000
compounds against 300 kinases okay and
people have done that okay so that is
the power of chemi informatics that is
the power of the knowledge that's
available um for for accessing
or accelerating the discovery okay
imagine having all these components
in your hands you have a
targeted library for kinases you have
kind uh you know we talked about kinase
selectivity panel you have focused
structure you know where exactly it
binds how it binds and why it binds more
importantly if you know all those things
and then of course if you know all the
mutations that are there all of it
becomes very very critical for coming up
with the molecule that is very very
potent and very very selective and then
only that particular molecule is
nominated as a as a drug okay
uh
we quickly go over
the animal models without getting into
the details once a molecule is
identified as very very important and
selective you go into testing their
efficacy in animal models
you carry out in vitro studies uh some
of the immutable studies with the
with the cytochrome p450s and other
things and then in vivo studies as shown
here this is a mouse model
that is
that is commonly used okay you you put
it you
you inject a tumor and create a tumor in
that mouse okay and now you inject this
particular mouse with the drug that is
that you think is very very effective
again this particular cancer type okay
and if if the drug is very effective
then the drug you know the tumor size
has to come down the tumor has to
essentially disappear so you carry out
lots of histopathology studies you carry
out elisa histopathologies aliza and
everything else to see whether
the drug is effective or not and
if the drug is really good this is the
type of data
you would like to see
this is untreated
animals okay the mouse model okay you
can see
just the vehicle alone
there's a control you know that the
cancer
is is there everywhere whereas you treat
it with the drug such as student suit
and this is a pizza drug you know has
been there the last 15 years or more you
know very very important effective drug
you can see
that within you know within a short
period of time that the tumor just
disappears okay this is a type of
molecule
we all aspire to develop in the pharma
industry okay
i'll quickly go through a
few a few more slides
okay this is development of a molecule
um a discovery of cemetery emitter
called crisotinib again developed
advisor for for
lung cancer okay um i want to show this
particular uh case uh
for
for you because you are you're
interested in taking the chemi
informatics course and it all
is related to this particular drug
discovery is related to
structure based drug design wherein
the scientists had developed
cement structure okay they had access to
three dimensional structure of cement
they knew where exactly the compound
binds and they use this particular
information to make about 800 compounds
in less than two years okay this is
amazing normally it takes four to five
years to have a program like this and
you will hear more about this in my
presentation on friday in personalized
medicine okay so
using structure-based drug design they
were able to come up with that with the
molecule
this original molecule you modify
modify and finally come up with the
molecule that eventually became became
the drug
okay the drug was very very effective it
is available everywhere in the world
okay you can see the difference
this is uh
you know untreated and this is treated
this is untreated lung cancer this is
treated you can see you know
and then of course you know it's also
effective
you know
this is uh
untreated and then after treatment the
tumor regression you can see saying that
you know that the drug is very very
selective and effect
and very effective against lung cancer
okay but then you know you start
developing uh
uh mutations for for any
uh
given
given tumor and you you have to develop
next generation drugs okay we call it as
first generation drug second generation
drug and third generation drug okay the
example i gave you christophine is a
first generation drug it works with you
know with some uh mutations but not all
the mutations okay but then the
scientists from pfizer and uh mark and
gsk they all came up with molecules that
are better than the first generation
comp molecules the second generation
compound and then of course we have
lorelan
again from from pfizer which is the
probably the best third generation drug
that's available for lung cancer okay
the advantage of this is uh is shown in
this particular
cartoon here
that i'm showing
with the pointer okay
in lung cancer when it reaches uh you
know
at a late stage
it can metastasize it
it can go to the other organs
and in this particular case it goes to
the brain so you start seeing you know
metastasis in the brain this particular
drug goes to the brain okay unlike
unlike many drugs that does not enter
the brain
loyal latino goes to the brain so it is
effective you know even if there are
some activities for this particular drug
in the brain okay which is which is
which is very good okay
so that was uh that was the last slide i
had wherein i told you the story of how
we develop
molecules um
starting from idea okay going through
cloning purification of protein
developing the assays and then running
high throughput screening in parallel
you you identify you get the
three-dimensional structure of the
protein you do structure based drug
design and then develop a lot of
molecules
um you know in a in a rational manner
and then take it through animal models
demonstrate the efficacy of those
molecules demonstrate they are not toxic
they are very selective and then
eventually
uh
if they are not toxic if they are very
safe
in the glp talk study then you nominate
them as a candidate ready for clinical
trials it goes through clinical trials
and if it succeeds after 10 10 years of
hard work 15 years of hard work it comes
to the market
okay and then it benefits the patient
okay
so so that is in in brief the entire
process of drug discovery and uh
i'll stop it here and then perhaps take
some questions and then we can get into
the career opportunities in uh
you know in
in drug discovery area or in chem
informatics
back to you sonalika
thank you so much sir for such a
wonderful session
and we are definitely looking forward to
uh
the session on april 22nd
where we are going to get some more
insights about just the topics that you
discussed with us today and
do we have any questions please put them
in the chat box
okay so if there are no questions i
think we are good to go ahead and now i
would like to invite dr raghavendran
dr raghavendra will be helping us uh
to understand the structure of the whole
program and he will take us through the
curriculum over to you sir
thank you i think dr kamath is still uh
yet to discuss career opportunities
which he said he will after the
after attending to some of the questions
is uh is that so sir
uh yeah yeah we can take some questions
and i need uh maybe two minutes to
highlight the importance of this
particular workshop and and the
opportunities uh
you know uh in the in the pharma
industry
yeah please go ahead sir please and you
can take the questions as they come up
okay okay yeah see um
you know for me um
chem informatics and the type of tools
that are available is really really a
blessing for people in drug discovery
okay it has uh
[Music]
you know it has
so many components that are that are
useful in the in the pharma industry or
biotech industry or in academia or
wherever okay that you are working or
wherever you are trying to make your um
you know career either pursuing your
studies further
or getting into industry and then
working okay
and these are these are the things that
everybody in the industry will be
looking for for you to know you know how
you can apply many of the tools that
mohits america and kuni they all talked
about they are very very important and i
think through these workshops you will
learn about the data analysis okay which
is part and parcel of i gave hydro put
as an example hydrogen string as an
example but data analysis the type of
data that that that are used in the
industry with you know
100 compounds against you know 200
targets or 1000 compounds against 100
targets all these are done you know by
using technologies that are being that
are being taught to you in the
informatics course work that that we are
talking about in silico screening again
is part and parcel of any of the pharma
industry biotech industry and is you
will learn a lot about this
during the workshop
uh structure-based drug design
structural biology work homology
modeling okay
the docking aspects of it again you will
hear a lot about this you learn a lot
perhaps you may get some hands-on
experience of doing this
during this workshop
all these things are are very very
critical
and
and
don't assume that is required all these
things are useful only in the pharma
industry okay i think when we talked
about it these are the tools okay
in the industry or wherever you're
trying to look for a job or in your own
career in academia
these will be useful tools okay it
doesn't matter how you want to utilize
it the ex the fact that you have
knowledge about all these things then
it's up to you how you want to use it in
your own area whether it's in life
science discovery or whether it's in
whether it's in
you know agriculture veterinary
or or you know in your own research that
where where you'll be able to use these
tools to use
to
understand the role of you know hundreds
and hundreds of data points okay so uh
so i think uh for me is is
it's a very very important uh workshop
that that you are
looking into participating and it will
greatly help you it will bring you up to
speed as to what's going on you have
access to all the tools and everything
else that others
others have okay so my suggestion
is you know take advantage of it you
learn a lot and it will improve your
your profile so i'll stop it there uh
it's only
thank you thank you very much sir uh
there are a couple of questions if you
if you have a couple of minutes more to
uh address them
there's a very broad question from
siloja who asks uh some of the reasons
for disapproval of a drug from fda
from
from fda
oh
yeah yeah no no this is a very uh very
good question
everybody looks for safety
okay
the molecule has to be very very safe
and people are
taking medicines for 20 years 30 years
if we if
i have arthritis and i'm living for you
know 20 years 30 years the drug has to
be safe for that long okay so it is
it is very very
critical for the fda to make sure that
that the drug
is very very effective
is safe okay effectiveness comes later
okay the drug is not effective nobody
will buy that drug anyway that's for the
farmer to make sure that it is effective
but making sure that the drug is safe
is the reason why fda
fba
you know uh does it takes a long time to
approve it and the rules are very very
stringent
thank you very much that that perfectly
answers it and one more carrier question
from manpreet carr she says she's a
small molecule crystallographer with a
phd and a master's in data science and
how she wants to get into data science
based roles in this drug discovery
process
so what are your suggestions or advices
for her to focus on
yeah yeah no i think
[Music]
data science is coming up
and
there are so many companies in india
working on it i don't know whether we
are looking for an opportunity in india
or outside uh don't don't uh you know
narrow down yourself or
for companies that are working on
structural biology the the the data
science component itself would be of lot
of interest to companies um you know
in india
uh companies such as uh you know i can
talk some of them which are which are
doing a lot of uh
crystallography studies but lot of
screening work a lot of bioinformatics
and chemicals companies such as sinjin
um and accelera and there are so many
other companies that are doing it origin
and
gvk
and jubilant and and there are quite a
number of companies shinjin again you
know working on many of these aspects so
i think opportunities are there you will
have to just
apply to so many
many of these places and then
then have a good interview
yeah thank you thank you thank you sir i
think country that answers your question
you have all the ingredients that is
necessary please go ahead and look at
the necessary uh all the companies
listed by dr cometh and you should get
lot of success
i think that is going to uh be all with
the question and uh
yeah can yeah if it is possible can you
share your contact there is a specific
question to you from samia who wants to
work with you maybe she can get in touch
with you in person
yeah yeah yeah you you can give my
contact information to her
sure sir sure thank you very much samia
i will share it with all of you uh in a
while when sonalika becomes uh when
sonica takes the stage thank you very
much dr khambha that was extremely
insightful and amazing talk
it it's a pleasure to listen to you
sure no no problem i think
i'm i'm happy that you are averaging
this workshop you know see
for a person like me
one of us had this access uh 10 15 years
ago and now you know this is everybody's
on par
in india or anywhere else you know in
developing world we have the same tools
same access same knowledge
um as what's in the west so you know i
think it's it's uh it should greatly
help all the participants to participate
in your
workshop and uh
you know contribute to
their
you know their success
thank you thank you very much sir
and if i may if you may stop your screen
sharing i can start with mine
sure okay okay
yeah
thank you
so with that wonderful lecture and
wonderful talk and extremely informative
talk from dr kamath
i want to ha i want to uh
take this opportunity to thank dr khamad
one more time
and i would like to introduce myself i'm
raghavindran bioinformatics mentor with
pine biotech and i will take this
opportunity to um
to welcome you all for today's session
one more time we are going to introduce
you to this program uh introduction to
chemi informatics and drug discovery um
and we already had an exciting and
informative talk on the advancements of
drug discovery by dr kamath and you
already had met dr puneet khakir
who will be one of your mentors for this
program and to do to begin with let's go
over the program in in general
so before even starting to discuss about
the program i want to point few things
about how
scientists and researchers are
harnessing big comics data and advanced
tools like artificial intelligence for
drug discovery so the past few years we
have witnessed the generation of bigomix
data across multiple modalities that
include genomics genomics
transcriptomics epigenomics
and metagenomics to name a few these
omics field are based on high throughput
technologies like next generation
sequencing technologies and these
technologies generate billions and
billions of data points on genes
proteins and other molecules that
characterize the biological systems and
biological phenomena
so this big data brings new hope and
also new challenges in translating these
data points to therapeutics
so we all know multiple targeted
therapies in the past have shown
efficacies without a well understood
clinical biomarkers for specifically for
response or resistance so what these
multiomics provides is this systems
approach multi omics based systems
approach aims to target a list of
diseases
or list of molecular features such as
transcriptomics or gene expression
signatures as uh expertly
um
described by dr karma this can be used
to complement the conventional target
based approaches so uh we also know that
um emerging artificial intelligence
methods that include deep learning and
machine learning could empower the use
of big data in both the therapeutic
discoveries and to identify predictive
biomarkers for patients response or
resistance to a specific uh
target or to specific
treatment
so how does these omics data in general
empower us in drug discovery so there
are various types of her mixed data that
describe in great detail the
intracellular and intercellular
processes associated with common
diseases so these datasets can be
analyzed to understand the biology
behind the host factors and these
datasets can even describes a microbe
describe the microbiome composition of
our bodies and these datasets can also
describe the environments we live in to
drive infection and cause deterioration
of health to destabilize the immune
system and to lead into clinical
manifestation of what we call as
diseases so a developing a thorough
understanding at the systems level of
the disease is going to complement and
in fact it is going to it has already
started to drive the conventional and
well-established methods of drug
discovery processes like target based
approaches
so with that context in that context
this particular program is actually
designed for beginners and students who
are eager to learn about the fascinating
field of chemi informatics drug
discovery and how computational
structural biology plays a major part in
these research fields the aim of this
program is to enable students and
researchers to use open source tools to
use or utilize to leverage public
repositories to gain more insights and
to develop quality research projects to
answer
key questions in structural biology for
example
so
interested students and researchers will
also have opportunity to learn about the
application uh of these
logic in in
in
programming tools and environment like r
and python for implementation of alpha
fall for example
to predict protein structure
so what does this program cover and who
will this who will benefit from such a
program so we start from absolute basics
like basics of structural biology what
are molecules that make the cells what
are they made of and how they interact
and how they function so what techniques
do we use to understand how thousands of
different molecules in each of our cells
work together to keep us healthy or to
define a phenotype of the cell and in
addition to this you will also learn
about
different kinds of protein which is a
macromolecule that aid biochemical
reactions or specific function that will
help the cells to hold their shape or
some kinds of proteins also help
transporting specific molecules in and
around the cell
etc
you will also learn how the structures
of these proteins are determined how
understanding the relationship between
the structure and function will enable
us in designing drugs based on specific
structure of the target tool
so in this context you will also get
introduced to essential methods like
structure based drug disco
drug design and how it is becoming an
essential tool for faster and more cost
effective efficient methods to discover
new lead data new lead molecules
so protein structural studies have
provided hundreds of new targets and
opportunities for future drug
discoveries i mean hundreds is uh is a
very uh conservative estimate
the speed at which these structural
investigations have occurred has to be
breathtaking as we all know
simultaneously the available of
availability of these data from protein
data bank repositories like protein data
bank and other
sources has benefited
us in the long history of making
structural data and metadata accessible
to the world
wide
community
so you will learn how to analyze these
publicly available structural data to
reveal interesting insights into the
three-dimensional structure of protein
targets that are extremely critical and
important for the discovery of new
trucks
so
we all know about the protein data bank
to tell a little bit about the protein
data bank uh as a small statistics will
reveal that the protein data bank
archive currently holds
more than 155 000 structures at that
atomic level of
atomic level of biomolecules and these
structures have facilitated the
discovery of about 90 percentage of the
new drugs approved by the us fda in the
cycle of 2010 to 2016 alone so that will
actually
tell you or underline the
importance of using structure based drug
discover
in the
context so this program as you have been
listening to it for a lot of times will
be led by the members of omics logic
industry expert panel like rabbi academy
pine biotech and renowned scientists
from accenture and reagent biosciences
so this research training is designed to
enable you students to learn basic
concepts of structural biology and to
start applying by working on utilizing
specialized algorithms and tools that
have been utilized by industry and
research labs to innovate discover and
answer some of the key biological
questions in chemi informatics and drug
store
so uh
so this program has already started with
uh with uh with an interesting talk from
dr karma and that that would have
actually given you a lot of information
to process so let's go over what is in
schedule for the future uh topics and
future sessions in this specific program
so this will be followed by tomorrow's
session on introduction to chemi
informatics by dr punet who you met
already earlier so you will learn an
introduction to structure interaction
and properties defining the structure
and interaction of molecules in general
you will also get insights into the drug
discovery pipeline and how to use
various tools into in the progress or in
the process of this pipeline so this
introduction lecture will be followed by
an invited session that is open to all
this industry-based or industry expert
panel session is scheduled for two days
starting 21st of april and 22nd of april
so the first target is on drug
repurposing by doctor uday saxena on
drug um yeah
[Music]
on on the topic of drug repurposing
which is also sometimes referred to as
drug repositioning so this is the
process of identifying novel therapeutic
potentials for already existing drugs
and discovering new therapies for
untreated diseases so
since this specific uh
drug repurposing work or studies relies
on data for existing drugs and discover
diseases and data that um
that
yes
and data that will uh fuel enormous or
that is fueled by the enormous growth of
publicly available large scale omix data
biological data biomedical data and also
electronic health related data so um the
availability of these data the
availability of the methods that are
associated with
advanced statistical methods like
artificial intelligence and machine
learning
with the access to high performance
computing has actually fueled or
accelerated the development of um these
computational drug repurposing
approaches
so this this session will be an
excellent start for you if you are uh
specifically from or if you are
highly uh
trained in data science and we were
looking forward to use lot of machine
learning and ai based tools to uh drug
discovery and other purposes
so this will be followed by the next
day's talk on precision medicine by none
other than dr khamad who you have
listened uh earlier and he had given
some key highlights or some key uh clues
to what he will be talking about on 22nd
of april so we know that
what precision medicine is as precision
medicine marks a new relationship
between genomics and drug discovery this
relationship will provide insights both
into the mechanism and potential
treatment options of a single patient's
disease and with that decision
so you will listen and learn a lot more
on these two industry export sessions
which is scheduled for 21 and 22 please
uh
please attend without fail
and then we then follow this up with our
scheduled third session by dr punet
hacker
who is going to be your primary mentor
for this program uh progressing from
that day so
this is scheduled as a very insightful
session on planned uh planned as an
insightful session or a hands-on session
on molecular modeling using swiss model
and alpha pole tools for
three-dimensional structural analysis of
a binding site analysis and prediction
of new prediction of structures for the
new sequences or other proteins
so the you will also get introduced to
tools and databases like modular swiss
model alpha fold chimera swiss product
and embl repositories to name a few
and then we will have uh we will have a
next session which will help you to find
download and explore relevant data
that is extremely critical to target
based drug discovery
what we what will you learn in this
session you will learn about big data in
terms of navigation in chemical space
you will learn about molecular
representation in ai driven drug
discovery
and you will get an overview of
application of these artificial
intelligence and structure based uh
drug drug design and virtual screening
of these
hits that you have designed and done um
so the next session in this program is
is now scheduled as a practical session
or a hands-on session where you will
learn about introduction to structure
chemical interaction through docking and
you will learn also how to use public
information of small molecular
structures and properties to screen
ligands based on its effectiveness in
binding or based on its binding
interaction or interaction with specific
target that you have already selected
and
the next session is actually planned as
an advanced session in advanced chemical
informatics so where you will
specifically learn how to use open
source tools like data data barrier to
calculate and to predict key properties
like drug likeness or lle to identify
new leads and
novel chemical representatives of the
leads that you have already
shortlisted
so
the whole program is then planned to
culminate into an industrial perspective
of how to design uh acame informatics
research project and to address the
opportunity uh to enroll yourself into a
full drug discovery or mixed logic
research fellowship program uh on 7th of
may and to top it off
to top this program we have a final
session
uh which is planned as a panel
discussion on the scope of chemi
informatics on the scope of
bioinformatics and drug discovery in
general so this panel
which will include renowned
scientists and mentors that you have
already listened to
will discuss uh opportunities present in
the industries and what are the skills
and what profiles are in high demand and
that this panel is also uh
will be will have specific time
scheduled to be an interactive session
with an aim of addressing current
opportunities and career options for
students who are interested in
the field of drug discovery in general
so with that i
take this opportunity to once again
welcome you all to sign up for this
highly informative program and i look
forward to meet you all in the upcoming
sessions thank you very very much for
your participation and
i hand over the podium to somalia thank
you so much
thank you so much dr raghav for
explaining the whole curriculum now i
would like to share my screen
and monthly uh to answer your question
yes you can definitely still join the
program no matter uh if you are in a
different country
so uh we'll be able to then send you the
recordings of each and every session and
you can go through the recordings and
we'll have a group i'll just explain you
all about how how do we stay connected
how can you all take questions from the
mentors so we have a slack group a skype
group and you can join these groups go
through the recordings at your own pace
and then come up with your questions uh
and the mentors will be able to guide
you with that
all right
so
and now it's time that i uh explain the
registration process to all of you
present here
you know many of you are really excited
to get started with chemi informatics
so i'll quickly put up
a form first of all in the chat box
those who have not uh fill the form if
you're interested to register for the
program please fill this form
the second thing is here is the link to
the program page
now on this program page
you will be able to first of all look at
the whole schedule of the program that
dr raghav just explained so the whole
schedule is mentioned here on the
program page you can go through each and
every session detail here
and then to register yourself
scroll uh down in uh on the program page
itself and you will be able to find
three different levels beginner
intermediate and advanced so you can
enroll picking up any of these three
levels uh that works best for you
now what are these three subscription
levels all about
in the beginner level you will have the
access to such
uh
sessions these group sessions you will
have the access to where you can listen
to the mentors recordings and also the
same access will be given to each one of
the person in these three different
levels in the intermediate level you
will get a chance to have one-on-one
uh meeting with the mentor to maybe
clarify your questions or
to clarify any of your research question
even if you are working on it and then
comes the advanced subscription where
you will get some extra time
apart from the whole duration of the
program itself and in this extra time
you can work on a nice good research
proposal with your mentor
so these are the three differences in
these three subscription levels you can
pick the option that works the best for
you and enroll yourself
so that was it about how you can
register for the
program
now
uh it's broken for you just a second
monthly i just send the link once again
and also if
you are not able
to fill the form maybe you can reach out
to us directly at support and refine.bio
or marketing at the rate omisojic.com
all right
[Music]
and uh
the question that manpreet asked about
her being in us and not being able to
attend the sessions like the same thing
applies to others as well those who are
in different parts of the world and if
the time doesn't work for you let's say
then you need not worry because we have
the recordings definitely we can do one
thing for such people you can go through
the recordings and maybe we can have a
live q a session at uh your schedule
time like you can propose a time to us
and then we can finalize a particular
time where we can meet and we can take
your
questions that you will come across by
going through all of these sessions
all right and by talk talking about the
recordings you will be able to also look
at these recordings here on the program
page itself so what i'll be doing is
i'll be just putting up the recording of
each and every session uh here on the
program page and you can revisit the
recording go through it and then click
on the complete session
all right so that was about how you can
register for the scheme informatics and
drug discovery program and tomorrow we
have a session by dr puneet so this was
a free webinar also i had a question in
the chat box asking if this is a free
webinar is it included in the program
it's a free webinar where we just wanted
to introduce infrastructure of the
program and also uh wanted our mentors
to introduce themselves
all right so now i'll just quickly uh
tell you more about the omixojic learn
portal and also help you navigate
through this portal and along with the
program that we have introduction to
chem informatics program we'll be having
various associated resources that you
all will be supposed to go through and
i'll just take you through this
particular course work as well that is
on structural biology and game
informatics for
drug discovery that you are supposed to
go through along with this particular
program as uh an associated online
resource
all right so i'll just share the link in
the chat box of the omixlogic learn
portal
uh okay raghav sir i'll just uh send the
link of the form once again in the chat
box
all right so this is the link to the
army logic learn portal in the chat box
once you visit this uh
portal you need to sign up and create an
account for yourself it's very easy you
just need to
create an account putting up the
credentials or you can
simply
sign up by any one of your using any one
of your social media accounts it could
be via google facebook linkedin etc so
i'll just quickly give you a demo
and you can create an account or use any
of your social media accounts i'll use
my google account
you can also
follow along and have an account for
yourself on the portal
once you have an account on the portal
please make sure that you update your
profile add a profile picture your name
should be entitled case add a brief bio
and also you you can link in your social
media accounts
now i'll be taking you through some of
the courseworks that you can go through
by having an account on the portal and
also by being a part of the program
now each and every coursework that you
complete first of all you can monitor
your progress here on your profile
and for every coursework that you
company you will get some points that
take that will take you from a business
level to an expert level
right and for every coursework that you
complete you will be able to get a
certificate here itself in your profile
tab download it and share your
achievement on social media platforms
all right now let's go back to the
courses tab
now how do you navigate the portal
uh so we have various courses and also
example projects or here on the portal
that you can go through and learn more
about so if you click on the courses tab
you'll find various courses here which
are uh on bioinformatics multi-omics
structural biology multi-omics includes
genomics epigenomics transcriptomics and
metagenomics and
then we have a course for construction
biology that you are supposed to go
through as an associated resource and
also a course book on data science which
uses r and python for biomedical data
analysis so by clicking on the course
tab
you
you will be able to um view all the
courses up here and then you can pick
the one that you would like to go
through and learn more about it same
goes for the example project simply
click on the project tag and the list of
all the example projects uh will be
listed now these example projects are
actually applications of the coursework
that you will be going through just to
have an idea that how the concepts
methodologies and guidelines to run
these pipelines on the server could be
applied to answer a particular research
question in hand
so that was it about the example
projects and coursework that you can go
through and now talking about the
structural biology and gaming
informatics um
work that you are supposed to go through
so as this program begins we have uh
uploaded uh the first lesson for the
uh program and this particular lesson is
a free lesson that you can definitely go
through and as we'll be proceeding along
with each and every session of chem
informatics program you will be able to
see the other lessons here as well which
you can go through practice do the
hands-on practical and take your
questions
i'm talking about the slack channel so
this is the slack channel that i was
talking about
and uh the program participants will be
a part of our slack channel not this one
is a general group but when we have a
particular program going on we we have a
group like this where all the uh program
participants are here and also the
mentors and you can clarify questions
here in the group itself
okay so uh those who are asking for a
fee uh waiver or
scholarships
uh you can email sparsh her at marketing
at the rate gmail.com
sorry omixlogic.com
and she'll be able to help you with this
also i'll quickly put the scholarship
form in the chat box
now when you will make sparsha at
marketing either at omnislogic.com
please let her know which uh
subscription level are you entrusted to
pick
and yes thank you sparsh for sharing the
contact number so we have an indian
contact number where you can call and
have a word with spash and she'll be
able to help you out with your
enrollment
so that was it about registration and
also about the portal and resources that
you'll get the access to now if there
are any other questions you can please
put them in the chat box and i'll be
happy to take them up
yes uh till then i'll just quickly share
the link to the form
uh
mantra is for now this is a one-time
course where we are having an
introduction to game informatics
and next month we are going to have an
advanced level of course
where we where we will be picking up
more advanced uh topics and also dig
more deep into the hands-on practice
right so this is a coursework where
we're getting started with chem
informatics and also we'll be discussing
various aspects and uh those who are
just about to begin with this particular
field i think this is very nice for them
and also for those students or
researchers who uh want to understand
more of the concepts
and listen to these industrial
experts i think this is the best program
for them
and after this we are going to have an
advanced level of coursework so what i
think is
that
they go like going through this
particular coursework will lay off a
very nice foundation for all of you
for the interested participants to take
up the advanced course right
and uh for now we have no plans of like
running this um maybe later but we'll
definitely update you
once um
we have such a plan
okay
so by talking about the certification
process when you talk about uh how well
certified these forces are globally
so uh
we are not definitely going to rate it
up but uh yes i think that uh these
these certifications are
globally accepted as they are certified
by
the most uh
like industrial exports and people who i
think have the best knowledge out of it
and to highlight more about the
certification process and
its global recognition i think dr raghav
can answer it much better than
manfred yes i mean we uh
as as it has already been clarified and
has
covered that we are involved with
variety of different universities all
around the world and this certificate is
globally valid but what the certificate
will give you in terms of skill in terms
of learning experiences you will learn
the necessary skills not just
and get a certificate for the validity
of those skills
if you
include the skills that you have learned
and the
courses that you have learnt in your
curriculum or in your resume
then you will have a
valid certificate to show for and and
also knowledge that you have acquired in
the process of going through this
program and in the process of going
through these courses will speak for
itself and we value that even
more or even uh
at a higher rate than uh than you
gaining certificate we
buy us
or we buy
a certificate from us will ensure that
we have learned all the necessary skills
and you are you will be able to converse
in the language or you will be able to
understand all the necessary methods in
any chemi informatics document or a
paper research paper
so that when you are going to apply for
new jobs and you will be able to for
example think independently in in these
uh using these algorithms and using
these processes
that that is what we will prepare you
for and this that is what this program
ah as an introduction will help you to
gain more insights and the advanced
program that nalika is going to talk
about is going to give you a lot more
practical experience and lot more
understanding of which methods to choose
for which question and which data so the
methods the question the data all of
them
you will have a lot of experience and
lot of
understanding
in in in the choices and also in
designing a project or the analysis
methods so i think that that will
partially answer your question and yes
many people have been using these
certificates and they are valid and they
are highly
[Music]
regarded in the job market globally
so any other queries regarding to that
uh so monkey as i explained that we have
three different levels it's not that you
definitely have to pick the advanced
level uh dollar 180 you can pick the one
that works uh works out for you when you
talk about the access of resources that
is session videos or
the recordings the associated resources
all of uh them are going to get the
access to it definitely
but the access is different uh just in
terms of
mentor availability right so in the
beginner level you can definitely pick
up your questions um in in the slack
groups but uh yes to have one on one
knee to the mentor intermediate would be
the best i think and advanced is for
those people who actually want to join
let's say um
post talk they want to join a post
opposition or a phd program there are
many students as well who wants to
join some masters program and they are
supposed to submit a research proposal
or maybe start with the research project
and
uh
like work on it and before that they
need to send the proposal to us as well
right so going through this literature
review and coming up with a nice good
proposal to work on your research
project and get started with it
is what i think people having this sort
of uh goal they should pick the advanced
level right
and also
throughout these sessions it's not just
a theoretical knowledge that you're
going to get you'll also go through the
practical hands-on analysis but if your
ultimate goal is to get a research
project out of this particular training
program
then i think you can pick the advanced
level and still if you want to pick the
advanced level but you think the cost is
way too high i have sent you the email
id in the chat box please contact
her and she'll help you out
with getting some good nice scholarship
for the advanced level
yes
and
perfect any other questions
all right if you have no more questions
i think we are going to end today's
session
and we will be meeting tomorrow now and
we'll hear from dr puneet
and he's talking about game informatics
we'll get started we'll get you all
started with introduction to game
informatics first of all and we also
talk about various tools and databases
tomorrow and go through some of the
tutorials and also learn more about the
file formats
so let's now catch up tomorrow at the
same time have a nice day thank you for
joining
you